So basically what we're
trying to figure out
is how our model changes based on
removing variables from the analysis.
To figure this out you just
need to remove variables
that have too many categories
within one predictor variable.
So how do you actually do this?
What I want to do is start with
what we've had built out already.
Which is the input data tool,
connected to our select tool,
which is connected to
our create samples tool.
After this part, I'm going to work and
tweak our actual model.
The first thing I'm going to do is I'm
going to bring in the field summary tool
and look at the categorical
variables with
how many uniques values
they have within them.
What I want to do is
actually just look for
the results for
only my different categorical variables.
So my customer's segment,
my income, redeemer,
region, status,
region and status fields.
I'm then going to bring in a browse
tool after the i or interactive result.
If you look at these different
categorical variables, we can see that
the customer segment income, and
region fields all have way too many
different categories to effectively use
with their logistic regression model.
The way to deal with this is
either combine them into a fewer
number of groups, or we should simply
just deselect all of it for our model.
So, in this situation
what I ask you to do
is if there's more than four categories.
Let's just deselect and not use that
field for our logistic progression,
but what I do want to notice
is that our redeemer field and
status fields, those fit
the category and they're good to go.
So let's now deselect
that field summary tool.
I'm going to go back to our
predictive category and
bring in a logistic progression tool.
Name the model and just like before
I'm going to select my target variable
as a redeemer field and then my
different potential predictor variables
which I'm going to choose as spend,
status,
stays per year, total days stayed and
years of loyalty.
Let me run this model now reducing
the total number of different potential
predictor variables and
let's view if the results change at all.
As you can see the r squared
value is now at 0.5865.
And, as well, we have three
statistically significant predictor
variables not including
the intercept value.
This is definitely one very valid
way to determine the optimal
predictor variables.
Yet, it is a very manual and
time consuming process.
Now what we're going to do is leverage
the stepwise regression technique
to automate this process.